[Music]
I am the head of data and AI at Bowery
farming and this not humble title ai
farming a hundred times the yield of the
data team of one I will I have to just
say right at the top there are more
people involved they'll mention them at
the end so we we say berry farming berry
the modern farming company modern
farming is not a self-evident term right
people farming all over the place
they've been doing it for a while
they're doing it now so when we say a
modern farming we mean a specific set of
technologies that we're using to make
farming more productive and meet all of
our needs as a growing world that needs
to be fed so the specific set of
technologies that we're talking about
are that we are growing indoors
we are growing entirely hydroponically
so there's no soil involved all of the
light in our farms comes from LEDs so
this is not a green house with natural
light it's all being provided by us to
the plants and it's vertical so we have
crops planted in in tiers all the way up
to the ceiling and you may have seen
this I'll show some pictures coming up
but that's how you get sort of the
highest density of productivity into a
room into a space and then the fourth
piece is that it's automated right we
want to take more and more of the
process of doing agriculture and make it
scalable right apply technology to get
more of that work done with less and
less input and why so I mean that's sort
of a cool set of technologies to throw
around but we don't do it just because
we are technophiles we do it because it
provides us these things that we all
care about so the first is our farming
technology is on the order of a hundred
times more productive per acre of land
right so in a world where we have less
and less arable land or less and less
space in general we get a hundred times
more productivity for a few reasons if
you think about an acre in you know the
outskirts of New York City our farms are
in Kearny New Jersey right now
how much of the year do you expect that
that farm is productive growing the
produce that you'd like to eat tonight
for dinner
only a little bit right because there's
this whole section of the year where
it's sleeting and the salt trucks are
driving around right and that's not
great for agriculture so we get that
part we get to grow year round we also
get to go vertical right so we get that
multiplier where instead of using this
what this acre once we get to use it
seven or ten times and then the third
piece is I don't know how many in this
urban crowd how many of you have lawns
you have to mow but you know that day in
the summer where it rains all weekend
and then it's super sunny on Monday and
by the time you get home from work on
Wednesday the grass is up to your knees
right it's because there's a set of
inputs that plants really thrive in and
outdoors you don't get that all the time
you're right you get this irregular
input of those input factors and so in
our farm it's that perfect summer sunny
day every day of the year right although
all the light all the water you could
need all the time and so those together
we can produce we can produce produce
for all of us to eat a hundred times
more productively than the same acre of
land traditionally at the same time but
we can be resource efficient and so
because we're indoors because we control
our environment really tightly we don't
need any pesticides so no no kinds of
regulation of pests or any sort of
biological threats to the plants right
so we don't even have to get into which
chemicals are safe to use or any of
those things we just don't use any of it
the one of my favorite ones 95 percent
less water so because this is a closed
system all the water we give to the
plants either ends up in their plant
cells as lettuce on your table or gets
transpired into the air and collected
and put back into the system and so
we're not dumping tons of water that
runs off into the nearby stream and then
finally we can build these farms close
to where people are eating the food and
so what that does is reduce the supply
chain complexity and all the supply
chain energy and also delivers a product
that is local and fresh for the people
that are eating it
so we serve a number of outlets that
you're familiar with here in the city
all of that food is created less than 10
miles from where you consume it right
and so that has a whole bunch of sort of
energy and complexity and systemic
benefits so Bowery is a company we are
three years old just turned three years
old a week or two ago we have 60
employees currently that includes
everyone who works at the farm and
everyone that works in the office and
Flatiron and we have been shipping
product to these outlets foragers
grocery stores Whole Foods sweet green
recently and a couple of really nice
restaurants in the city for maybe almost
two years now
so we've been in the market for a long
time and this business is all about not
proving that we can bring lettuce to the
market but that we can do it at scale we
can do it better than it's been done
before so haven't really said anything
about the AI yet right it's fun to throw
around AI but you have to make sure
you're specific what you mean about that
and why that's valuable so I think about
AI in our world in three pieces
the first is operational so we have a
lot of constrained operation sort of
challenges where we need to get the most
utilization the most efficiency out of
our farm because this whole business is
based on being able to produce the most
product the most efficiently and so I'll
get into sort of an example of each of
these later but there are a lot of
things you can you can imagine finding
the right home so crop positioning
finding the right place to put each crop
within the farm is a data science
problem
there's mission AI problem you can think
about task ordering how do we do how do
we organize the work so that all the
harvests and all the transplanting and
all the seeding happens in the most
efficient way in a way that gets the
most the most productivity out of our
farm workers second category it's
informational there's a whole bunch of
when you think about someone who has a
real green thumb right or someone who
has a ton of experience in agriculture
has been running a farm for a long time
they are walking or
constantly looking at the crops noticing
what's going well what's going poorly
and making adjustments all right that
doesn't scale very well to our 50 feet
tall
you know warehouse long you know
thousands of different crops to keep
track of kind of a system and so the
opportunity here is how can we extract
and structure that data in a way that
lets a smaller number of those people
use that same expertise to manage a
larger number of crops and so in this
world we have things like computer
vision so how can we have thousands of
eyes on these crops that are growing
instead of one person walking around and
bring to their attention the things that
they need to react to that they need to
interpret or bring their expertise to
and so the AI is sort of in that
component is how can we allocate our
human attention ray our human resources
to the crops will most benefit from it
and then third is agricultural right
obviously at the end of the day what we
want to be really good at is growing
these crops better than than other
people have been able to grow them and
so that really comes down to finding the
perfect recipe so in this new indoor
farming world we get to choose a lot of
the features right we get to choose a
lot of the experiences the crop has how
much light what temperature how much
humidity how much nitrogen should be in
the water all of these factors that the
plants care a lot about but they care
differently the different crops want
different things and so I think about
this problem fundamentally as a high
dimensional search all right we've got
you know a ton of different levels we
could choose in terms of light intensity
we can cross that with how much nitrogen
at a bunch of different levels right
that gives us tons of you know
potentially millions of different
recipes we could try for each crop and
we have to find a way to search that
space and find better and better recipes
all the time now you may be thinking
this is all very techy and an exciting
and saying AI is fun but people looking
for better ways to grow crops is not new
you didn't come up with that and in fact
that is sort of the definition of
agriculture right people found things
that they wanted to eat and then I said
I wonder if I could do this a little bit
differently and get a little bit more to
eat and we are not doing anything
different so this is an Inca Terrace
from the 15th century so not only were
they already experimenting right 600
years ago trying to say if we did this a
little bit differently would we have
more to eat
they had already gone vertical right we
already got nine levels of farming going
on there this is you know two more than
we've got so what's exciting about this
is not that we've come up with the idea
of doing experimentation doing data
driven incremental improvement in
agriculture it's that we have this
orders of magnitude bigger opportunity
in searching that space so if you think
about open field farming and you think
about agricultural opportunities in two
dimensions the first dimension on the x
axis here is how much of what the plant
cares about do you get to control so the
open field farming you get to control
what fertilizer you put down you know
maybe once or twice a year you can
control that you could you can control
how often you rotate the fields and so
sort of roughly what else is in the soil
but you don't get to control the
temperature or how much it rains or
whether there's a big store that storm
that damages all your crops or how much
light it gets right if it's cloudy all
all all spring all these huge factors
that the plants care a lot about you
just have to sort of take your chances
with at the same time the other thing
that we know you know any sort of
machine learning problem any sort of
learning problem in general the most
important thing is how many times do I
get to ask the question get some
feedback and iterate and in the world of
open field farming you plant your crops
once per year right and you maybe have
multiple fields so you can sort of try a
couple of different things per year but
you plant once you work all season to
develop those crops and at the end of
the year you figure out if you did a
little bit better than last year or not
definitely possible to make progress and
people were working on that for
millennia
but slow-going greenhouses right so the
last you know couple hundred years
roughly give us the opportunity to
control more right you can control
temperature through a much larger part
of the portion of the year and you get
mult
white so you can learn faster in a
greenhouse than you can in an open field
where we are in the world of vertical
farming is all the way at this other end
of the scale where we can control almost
everything that the plants care about we
get to choose values for all those
things and at the same time we get to
search really quickly through all of
those possibilities right and so in a
farm like this you can get sort of a
first glimpse into you know the sort of
scale we're talking about each of those
different growing areas there we can
choose all of those different
combinations and so through the course
of the year we get thousands of chances
to evaluate a recipe for each crop and
so that equation right that control by
iteration speed gives us the ability
potential gives us the opportunity to
really drive advances in agriculture but
if sort of Falls to to the AI team then
to deliver on that promise right and so
one thing that I was most excited about
in joining Bowery about a year ago is
that these little cartoons were part of
the Bowery pitch well before I started
write this pitch that we were going to
close this loop between learning about
the crops and feeding back in and
growing more effectively was part of the
the origin idea of the company so
there's part of the founding premise but
of course now it's time to deliver right
we've built the infrastructure we're
growing these crops who are collecting
the data how do we drive that actually
back into creating more value with the
company and so I think so that the idea
that I wanted to bring to this talk was
how in a small organization are with
limited resources or however many
resources you have how do you prioritize
closing that loop right because they're
all there's a lot of work you can do
that's really hard and really valuable
right to you you can see how much order
you're bringing to the world
you know improving the modeling of your
warehouse or logging more things than
you're allowing before so that you can
understand it but the end of the day you
got to think about closing that loop
right getting back into and so what are
we driving back into the business so
that it starts working better and so I
think of that process is looking
something like this where data is coming
from places in the world that you don't
control and of course we always have
complaints about that data all right
it's messy it's incomplete it doesn't
tell us all the stories that we want it
to tell and so we do a lot of work in
this ETL area right where we model data
into a well structured warehouse or some
other data store that we control so that
it meets the needs of people asking
questions that's great that's a super
important first step now you've got
structure and you've got order the next
step is doing something clever with that
right and doing something clever can
mean a lot of things right it can mean
deep learning all you know self-driving
cars or it can mean defining a KPI that
lets people understand what changed in
the business all right there a lot
there's a broad scope of clever but no
matter what that clever is once you've
built that part of the pipeline then
you've got to send it back in so that it
changes something about your world and
so that's either you know sort of the
way I'm describing it through some sort
of reporting where you help people
understand the world and then they make
decisions or as a data product back into
the system right whatever the
application is whatever the the thing is
that you're trying to automate so
closing this loop or thinking about how
we can build data infrastructure that
lets us close this loop as quickly and
as lightly as possible was really
central to my goal and sort of my
strategy in working on this problem at
Bowery because for I've been there a
year for nine of those months I was the
only person doing data work all right so
I need to close this loop improve value
that we can do these things that we can
say let's automate part of this process
here let's do recipe search without
really neat without spending you know a
year building all of these different
engineering projects and so yeah
sometimes I just like to throw cool
pictures from the farm in because that's
that's a lot of the fun of working here
so this is a picture of our recently
open farm and car
you can see any of the things that we
want to know about it or want to control
for it is controlled on those unit and
so that you can think about that as our
experimental unit or as our primary unit
of data and they go as far as they I can
see because we want to do it be doing as
much of this as possible in parallel and
so this is sort of the icon heavy
overview of the the architecture that
allowed us to do all of this to close
that loop really lightly and that's
that's what I've been really excited
that we've been able to accomplish as a
team is how easy it has been to connect
this loop so the the pieces of this
puzzle and I'll break these into a
little bit more detail but the pieces
are you can see and everybody in this
room probably recognizes AWS icons we
were already an AWS operation on the
software side so I made sense to really
you know steer into that world and so
we've got all the data that I don't
create right from from the world of
sensors from the in-house applications
and from things like s3 all hitting the
message bus so we use an SNS sqs message
bus that all of those applications are
already natively broadcasting everything
that happens to them in so everything
that happens is it what's an example
when a new crop is created right a new
crop is seeded the software service that
manages crops post a message that says
new crop crop ID 1 2 3 and it goes
across the message bus same with a
sensor that just measured that it the
humidity in the room is 52% goes across
the message bus everything goes across
the message bus and so what I do then is
just take all of that with Kinesis and
throw it into a redshift load schema so
I just have this whole history of all
the data of the boat that the company
has created and one one definitely one
differentiating aspect of this world of
data
is that it's all first party I don't
have any web analytics I don't have any
clicks I don't have any ad retargeting
anything right it's all this sort of a
universe that we've defined and so
that's definitely like a simplifying
advantage but the result is I have a
single world of streaming data coming
through that Kinesis just puts all into
redshift for me and so from from that
load schema I use DBT that I think a lot
of people here are familiar with DBT is
a Python open source Python library in
which you express templated sequel to
ask for models that you want right so
given and I'll go into more detail given
all this this data that I have coming
into the load schema this DBT is how I
define what I want to see in my
warehouse give me the table of crops and
so and Center is there hosted running
service so or orchestration service and
so those tools together is is all that's
involved in going from this Universal
stream of data coming in to a warehouse
I can work on the next whole piece here
is that sort of whatever tools we want
to use right the design is just query
the dare the data warehouse to define
your world do whatever you want to it
and then put it back on the message bus
and so that's all I'll sort of I'll get
into some examples of different things
that we've worked on in that project or
and sort of in that portion of the world
but the idea here is just this is one
more piece participating in the message
bus world and so that's how we close the
loop and so now I'll jump into some
examples I think I talk through most of
that is just the the labelled version
but so this is an example of how it's of
how simple it is basically so everything
all messages all all data that happens
in our world ends up in this load
messages table and they all have message
types and timestamps right so basically
every message has a message type a
timestamp and a JSON payload and if I
to define a table that has all the
temperature readings I just select those
types of messages out of the bus I
extract from its JSON the values that
they care about and give it a tamped
timestamp and now I have a payloads
alright sorry and now I have a table of
temperature readings and one thing that
DBT has built in is incremental
additions to tables like this and so
while this load table gets enormous
pretty quickly you're always just
incrementally parsing out the JSON from
the most recent records since the last
time you've run so that happens what I
call that streaming load so Kinesis is
handling all the time giving me new data
into my load schema incremental extract
so every time we run DBT we just parse
out all of the information that we care
about from all the messages that are new
and then the last step of that is that
on a batch schedule so we run hourly all
of the data that that we've extracted
then gets transformed into things that
we care about right so we don't care
about every temperature reading from
every sensor really sort of abstractly
we care what the temperature was in this
part of the room during this hour and so
this in that part of the process is
where we do our aggregation our summary
anything that we need to ask the
questions that are important to us one
thing that I've found about this pattern
that like changes the the stress and
dependency between the data team and the
software team is that all messages end
up in this load schema even if I'm not
ready for them right even if so a
constant example is we changed the
schema of this event or we invented a
new kind of thing so what happened
recently we started we brought online
automatic control of irrigation so when
the irrigation turns on and off for
every zone as a new kind of message
right irrigations turning on at this
time I don't have to be ready to ingest
that right and I don't have to start
pulling anything or being ready to pull
that into
warehouse when that event starts its
waiting for me in the load schema right
when that starts happening and going
over the message bus that are now
irrigation on and irrigation off
messages and I can write this
incremental extraction three weeks later
when I get to it and get all of that
historic data about when the irrigation
came on and off and then sort of catch
up and do that modeling work and that's
so it is really helpful for new things
it's also really helpful when something
changes there's never anything lost
right we have the whole history of all
the data that was recorded and we just
have to do whatever sequel might be
necessary to get that back in the shape
that we want it to be in and then and
then the last piece of that that closing
the circle idea closing the loop idea is
that whatever you're doing with that
data that's in the in the clever AI
bucket whatever tools you're using the
only requirement is you have to be able
to post whatever whatever you're
creating back to the message bus from
that and so this is an example this is
an abstract example where we made a
clever prediction of 42 and that's all
it takes in Python to put it back on the
bus right so we're all in the AWS
ecosystem here so if you're implementing
something using a tool like tensorflow
or like google o our tools at the end of
it all you have to do is say and here's
the new information that I created so
I'll go into a couple of specifics one
other thing that I think is just so cool
about being able to stand this up
especially a small company is this is
all infrastructure that will continue to
work for the next couple of years we'll
definitely run into scaling challenges
along the way but we're running tens of
millions of messages a month right which
is not big media company big but it's
one person data data team pretty big and
all of these tools come together for you
know less than a thousand dollars a
month right and our pretty you know plug
together a bowl without a ton of you
know I wasn't a data engineer before
this role I am still not a data engineer
but all of these tools really just sort
of testament to how much is available in
the cloud and the open source tools that
we use to manage that that
this is really not something you have to
like ask your boss to set up right it's
like I get these tools this is this is
doable without a big commitment
another good picture so how about some
examples so this picture again shows
sort of each of these trays of crop
needs to get put somewhere in the system
and so an example of one of the problems
that we solve is where should we put
each tray right if you have someone
whose job it is to take each tray from
the processing floor and find a home for
it they will be quickly overwhelmed
there are too many choices and too many
things to consider and so this is sort
of a classic warehouse problem right so
where do we put everything that needs to
go on the shelves except for we have
more things that we need to consider so
this is from a sort of our perspective a
bipartite graph minimization problem so
what a bipartite graph means is that we
have a known set of crops that need
homes we have a known set of homes and
it has to end up one-to-one at the end
of the day right every crop needs to end
up in exactly one home every home needs
to contain exactly one crop and so this
graph needs to have a number of edges
that is exactly equal to the two sides
and you can't use anything twice and so
Google are our tools is a terrific clean
interface to this world of solvers that
people have you know that this field is
been working on for ages and the job is
just to express what you're what you're
trying to solve which is non-trivial
right expressing what you want out of
this problem is not a is not a small
project but the the technology layer is
terrific to work with so an example of
what we're trying to minima or trying to
express here we have a lot of the farm
is broken up into different areas where
you can turn the irrigation zone
irrigation on and off if we're trying to
place 50 crops in today don't put them
in 50 different irrigation zones right
then we have to turn a lot of different
things on and off you want to pack those
crops into the smallest number of
irrigation zones as you can so that you
have to turn all
and off the fewest number of things
right to reduce the sort of management
load at the same time you don't want all
of those crops to be randomly in the
farm because the whole argument here is
that we're giving every crop exactly
what it wants so if you've got an area
that is warm and humid for for crops
that like that and one that is cold and
has tons of bright lights for crops they
want that you have to get those crops
ideally all into the environments that
they prefer and then the third piece or
a third example of a dimension we care
about is the retrieval time so what you
don't want to do is put something that
you want on next Monday behind a bunch
of things that you don't need until next
Friday Rex and you're gonna have to move
everything and put it back later and so
we use Google are our tools we define
the problem we run it nightly and then
that you know that's running on an ec2
instance when it figures out what its
solution is it posts all of those
position recommendations to the bus and
then the front end application that the
farmers are using in the farm listens
for those position recommendations and
integrates that into the UI that they
are using to get that work done so
that's how sort of following really
closely but how Pilon is describing that
separation of concerns letting us work
on this problem using whatever tools we
need to and then just posting
recommendations onto the message bus
lets us work on that and iterate without
being part of how that gets visualized
and communicated to the farm operators
another cool piece this is sort of a
view from close above a crop an early
early stage seedling crop is we're
trying to create new information here
right we don't want to just take what
people have already written down about
the farm and then tell them how to
management manage it we want to create
new information so that people are able
to manage in a way that they haven't
been able to before so what you're
seeing here is an image looking down at
a crop from one of the cameras that we
have mounted above every position on the
left is the raw image that's corrected
collected you can see that it's fisheye
because we're pretty close to the
subject area so we want to see as much
as possible
on the right is a mask that's been
applied indicating what portion of the
image shows canopy all right so we're
identifying here is what we're seeing in
this image that is plant canopy and what
is not it seems kind of easy as a human
right you know just point to all the
green stuff and we have green stuff that
is not plant right you can see some
algae growth there on the on the raft we
have plants that are not green
right and so this problem is a great
deep learning problem and so this is
using in-house training on our image
data on top of deep plaid which is deep
lab which is a CNN and we apply this
using tensor flow on lambdas actually so
when when the cameras take new images
they get passed through this deep
learning mask and what we get is this
graph on the left so you can see over
time the amount of the image that is
occupied by canopy is growing and a
pretty like that looks like a real
biological process that's happening
there right you can see the plant the
crop growing and then asymptoting at
full coverage what's what that lets us
do is compare how quickly crops are
growing alright so you imagine of like a
very simple experiment where you give
one crop less light than the other you
can see how much more quickly the second
crop grew than the first
it also lets us manage the farm
intelligently once a crop has closed
right the canopy has closed now the
leaves are continuing to grow but some
of them aren't getting access to the
light anymore and so that's a that's
when you've reached your sort of peak
biological productivity and you want to
either take that out in harvester or
transplant it and so it gets more room
[Music]
third so that was it that's a picture of
a crop that's down and being worked on
by a farm our produce third instance of
using the third category here is
agricultural this is a just such a
straightforward machine learning problem
or prediction problem how much will each
crop weigh how much will we be able to
harvest from each crop right so
very simple version of this is what's
the average the a crop of a certain type
has weight over the last you know three
years that we've been doing this well
that that's great
one of the things that our customers
care most about is a reliable supply of
this you know sort of hard to predict
commodity right we recently launched a
partnership supplying sweet green with
basil so if you go to a sweet green
there's one right across the street here
and get a salad basil in it it could
well have come from one of our farms
what they care about most is being able
to just keep that basil coming in the
door and not worrying about it right
they have a supply chain problem and so
what we can do is say given all the
crops we've grown given all the crops we
have in the system right now how much
light they've gotten how much water
they've gotten and how much we've been
able to measure their canopies growing
or what rate that canopy is we can
growing how many pounds are we going to
be able to ship on Tuesday all right we
can have very granular very specific
production forecasts so that we can be
an agricultural supplier that works more
like a manufacturing supplier right and
say we know exactly what we're going to
deliver you and and when it's going to
get there so this is what closing the
loop looks like to us we take all the
data of all the different kinds that we
get from our IOT world from in-house
applications from s3 and other data
objects everything's coming over the bus
we let Kinesis put it all in redshift
for us we use DBT to transform it all
into a warehouse that means the things
that we want it to mean
and then whatever cool a I project that
we're working on we put that information
back in the bus so that it can be
integrated with the other processes data
team of one was the story when I started
is not anymore so Henry and Kevin on the
software side huge in helping to design
this message bus architecture from the
beginning and then say Marianne and
Katie on my team now doing data science
and computer vision and one thing that's
cool with having a consumer facing brand
is you
come see me after this in office hours
are on Twitter you can also stop by a
Whole Foods pick up some arugula or some
kale or some powder head and close the
loop that way thank you
[Applause]
so variability is part of the
forecasting problem right and so part of
the production planning process is not
just having a point estimate but having
a confidence interval on what we what we
will deliver and so developing models to
us means being unbiased but also
decreasing that uncertainty because what
we what we end up having to do and I
think what a lot of sort of production
processes do is not plan to sell
everything that you expect to grow and
so if our forecast says that we will
grow a thousand pounds next week we'll
probably commit to sell some fraction of
that you know maybe nine hundred of it
to account for the fact that we you know
we expect variability there so we take a
statistical approach to avoiding shorts
but obviously the better we can get at
that prediction the more efficient we
can make the farm in terms of
productivity and selling everything that
we grow
[Music]